>>> THE RELEASE OF THE REDACTED
AFFIDAVIT ON THE SEARCH OF
MAR-A-LAGO IS RAISING CONCERN IN
DONALD TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM THAT
HE COULD BE INDICTED.
BUT, IS A DOJ PROSECUTION OF A
FORMER PRESIDENT WORTH THE RISK
OF THE EXTREME RESPONSE THAT
COULD RESULT FROM REPUBLICANS
AND TRUMP SUPPORTERS?
AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES" NOTES IN
A BRAND NEW EDITORIAL, QUOTE,
THIS BOARD IS AWARE THAT IN
DECIDING HOW MR. TRUMP SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE UNDER THE LAW,
IT IS NECESSARY TO CONSIDER NOT
JUST WHETHER CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION WOULD BE WARRANTED,
BUT WHETHER IT WOULD BE WISE.
NO AMERICAN PRESIDENT HAS EVER
BEEN CRIMINALLY PROSECUTED AFTER
LEAVING OFFICE WHEN PRESIDENT
GERALD FORD PARDONED RICHARD
NIXON, HE ENSURED THAT NIXON
WOULD NOT BE PROSECUTED FOR
CRIMES COMMITTED DURING THE
WATERGATE SCANDAL.
FORD EXPLAINED THIS DECISION
WITH THE WARNING THAT SUCH A
PROSECUTION POSED GRAVE RISKS OF
ROUSING UGLY PASSIONS AND
WORSENING POLITICAL
POLARIZATION.
MY NEXT GUEST PRESIDED OVER
DONALD TRUMP'S SECOND
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL AS PRESIDENT
PROTEM IN THE SENATE.
HE FIRST CAME TO WASHINGTON AT
THE AGE OF 34 IN 1975, RISING TO
BECOME THE THIRD IN LINE FOR THE
PRESIDENCY AS WELL AS THE CHAIR
OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
AFTER NEARLY HALF A CENTURY IN
OFFICE, AS ONE OF THE
LONGEST-SERVING MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE, HE'S RETIRING AND
REFLECTING ON HIS CAREER IN A
BRAND NEW MEMOIR TITLED "THE
ROAD TAKEN."
JOINING ME NOW IS THE DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR FROM THE GREAT STATE OF
VERMONT, PATRICK LEAHY.
SENATOR, I WAS REMINDED IN
READING YOUR GREAT MEMOIR YOU'RE
A FORMER PROSECUTOR.
LET ME ASK ABOUT THIS ISSUE OF
THE DAY, SHOULD THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT GIVE ANY
CONSIDERATION TO THE PROSPECT OF
CIVIL UNREST AS THEY DETERMINE
WHETHER TO INDICTMENT TRUMP?
>> WELL, I'M SURE THAT IS GOING
TO BE A CONSIDERATION.
AND I CAN THINK HOW PROSECUTORS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO WRESTLE
WITH THIS QUESTION WHEN IT IS A
FORMER PRESIDENT ON THE ONE
HAND, DO YOU SAY IF IT'S A
FORMER PRESIDENT YOU CAN'T
PROSECUTE.
OR ON THE OTHER HAND, DO YOU SAY
NOBODY, NOBODY, IN THIS COUNTRY
IS ABOVE THE LAW?
WHETHER THEY'RE PRESIDENT,
FORMER PRESIDENT OR ANYBODY
ELSE.
IT WILL BE A DIFFICULT QUESTION,
A LOT MORE DEPENDENT ON WHAT
COMES OUT OF THESE PAPERS THAT
WERE SEIZED.
YOU KNOW, DONALD TRUMP HAS SHOWN
A DISDAIN FOR CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL WHEN HE WAS EARLY ON IN
HIS PRESIDENCY, HE DISCLOSED TO
THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER
WITH A CAMERA GOING AND A
RECORDING MACHINE GOING IN THE
ROOM VERY, VERY TOP SECRET
INTELLIGENCE, WHICH PUT IN
DANGER ONE OF OUR ALLIES
CLANDESTINE EFFORTS.
IT PUT IN DANGER THEIR AGENTS.
THEY HAD TO YANK THEM OUT OF THE
COUNTRIES WHERE THEY WERE.
IT WAS SOME OF THE MOST
SENSITIVE INFORMATION WE HAD.
AND IN A BRAGGING WAY HE GAVE IT
TO THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER.
NOW THAT MAY BE BECAUSE OF THE
FEELINGS HE HAS TOWARD RUSSIA.
HE ALSO WHEN PUTIN WENT INTO
UKRAINE, HE CALLED HIM A GENIUS.
I CALL HIM A WAR CRIMINAL.
>> I'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT A
PROSECUTOR NEEDS TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER
THERE'S SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE OF A
CRIME HAVING BEEN COMMITTED AND
A BELIEF THAT THEY CAN
SUCCESSFULLY PROSECUTE SOMEONE
FOR THAT CRIME.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO.
WHEREIN LIES THE CITATION FOR
THIS THIRD CONSIDERATION OF FOR
LACK OF A BETTER DESCRIPTER THE
IMPACT ON SOCIETY.
>> WELL, I WAS A PROSECUTOR, AS
YOU SAID, FOR EIGHT YEARS.
I HAD TO MAKE DECISIONS WHO TO
PROSECUTE.
I PROSECUTED DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS, PEOPLE IN HIGH
OFFICE.
I HAD TO DO IT, BUT I WAS NEVER
FACED WITH A QUESTION LIKE THIS.
I WOULD SAY INCIDENTALLY,
EARLIER, YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
FRAUD AND THE COVID MONEY.
I WOULD PROSECUTE THOSE PEOPLE
TO THE FULLEST EXTENT.
I WANTED TO SEE THEM GO TO
PRISON.
I WANT THE EXAMPLE MADE THAT IF
YOU COMMIT FRAUD ON A GOVERNMENT
LIKE THAT, YOU'LL GO TO PRISON.
YOU WON'T GET A SLAP ON THE
WRIST.
YOU WON'T GET A FINE.
YOU'LL GO TO PRISON.
>> SENATOR LEAHY, QUOTE, THE
SENATE IS A BROKEN PLACE.
I READ AND REALLY ENJOYED
ELEMENTS OF YOUR BOOK.
AMONG THE MANY VIGNETTES YOU
TALK ABOUT IRON MIKE MANSFIELD
WITH HIS BACK ROOM BAR.
IT OCCURS TO ME THAT IF THE BACK
ROOM BAR EXISTED TODAY IN THE
SENATE, IT WOULD BE SEGREGATED
BY Rs AND Ds.
LIKE WHEREIN LIES THE BREAK OF
THE COMRADERY THAT YOU ENJOYED
FOR SO MANY YEARS THAT NO LONGER
EXISTS.
>> WELL, IT WAS A GRADUAL THING.
I THINK A LOT OF IT CAME AFTER
THE -- WHAT NEWT GINGRICH DID IN
THE HOUSE IN POLARIZING AND
IGNORING THE EXAMPLE OF HIS
PREDECESSOR, BOB MICHAEL.
AND SAID IT WILL BE ONE PARTY
CONTROLLING ISSUES, AND A LOT OF
THOSE MEMBERS CAME TO THE SENATE
AND FELT THE SAME WAY.
I'VE ALWAYS FELT THE SENATE
SHOULD BE THE CONSCIENCE OF THE
NATION.
WE OUGHT TO COME TOGETHER.
I'VE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL IN A
LOT OF LEGISLATION I'VE PROPOSED
BUT ONLY BECAUSE I'VE GONE AND
SOUGHT OUT REPUBLICANS TO WORK
WITH ME.
ACROSS THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
THEY'RE SLOWLY COMING BACK TO
HAVING SOME MEETINGS TOGETHER.
BUT IT'S BECOME TOO POLARIZED.
WE USED TO HAVE A DINING ROOM
WHERE REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
WERE IN THERE, AT EACH OTHER'S
TABLE, TALKING OVER ISSUES.
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF BOTH
PARTIES WOULD COME AND JOIN.
AND THINGS GOT WORKED OUT.
IT'S NOT HAPPENING THAT WAY NOW.
AND IT IS TOO POLARIZED.
WE HAVE SEEN FAR AND FAR MORE
FILIBUSTERS THAN EVER BEFORE.
IT IS NOT THE WAY THE SENATE
SHOULD OR COULD BE.
ONE OF THE REASONS I WROTE THE
BOOK "THE ROAD TAKEN" WAS TO
SHOW THE ARC OF WHERE THE SENATE
HAD BEEN, WHAT IT COULD BE AND
WHERE IT'S ENDED UP.
NOW, WE HAVE SOME TIMES COMING
TOGETHER, AID TO UKRAINE NUMBER
ONE.
NOWHERE NEAR ENOUGH AND IT'S
HURTING THE COUNTRY.
>> I THINK THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
READ THE MEMOIR AND I RECOMM